finding hope in our housing crisis help
is there but you have to know where to
look and how to navigate the system when
things do go wrong Heather Mills sat
down with the homeowner who nearly
during the pandemic but thanks to the
help of a local non-profit his door is
open and his heart is full
of a time that enjoyment the family
comes to hang out not just a house a
home mom has keys my nieces have keys
all says just leave me a plate of food
and don't leave a mess Ron Overton moved
to Las Vegas in 1992 he brought his
whole family it makes me happy seeing
them enjoy my house too
that's the reason I bought it so
everybody can enjoy it a space full of
memories and fun working on my house
brings me a lot of Joy until it became a
place of worry when the pandemic first
hit I lasted maybe six months before my
money start to run out I'm boring
leaning on my Mom calling friends and
stuff like that trying to get people to
move in with me so I can you know charge
a little rent something like anything I
could do to save my house as a bartender
on the Strip Ron was able to eventually
get back to work but he was fighting
multiple sclerosis and A lender he says
wasn't willing to work with him my Ms
kicked in I'm nervous and stress is the
worst thing for MS so once the stress
kicked in then you're going to work it
got to a point so I couldn't work
anymore he says it was an exhausting
battle I have reapplied at least 40
times
and that went on for two years I was
into my robe I just didn't know what
else to do and I was just calling
anybody and everybody hi thank you for
calling Neighborhood Housing Services of
Southern Nevada that's when Neighborhood
Housing Services of Southern Nevada was
able to help cut through the red tape
even when I was giving up she
is not just a house to some people
Michelle Merced the president and CEO of
nhssn says her staff is small and mighty
and they work hard for our community
because they understand how important it
is to have a foundation my dad would
always say it's the American dream to
live here in the United States you know
and to have a house but she admits they
have their work cut out for them we're
already starting to see an uptick in the
request for foreclosure counseling so we
want to get ahead of that in addition to
foreclosure prevention nhssn helps with
homebuyer education down payment
assistance pre and post purchase
counseling and affordable units today we
own and manage about 159 units that are
scattered throughout the valley
um these are all affordable housing but
the need is great Nevada has a shortage
of about 85 000 affordable units for Ron
it took years of saving to achieve his
dream of home ownership but nearly lost
it all when the pandemic hit this house
was everything to me it's my retirement
and it is once again he says because of
nhssn this is
my Oasis I love to hang out
home sweet home Heather Mills 8 News Now